eeuu sufrió en este país su única
derrota militar ocurrió en la década de
los 60 y 70 en la que fue una guerra
pero larga y muy impopular
tanto que terminó con la carrera
política del presidente demócrata lyndon
johnson y supuso de facto el fin del
modelo estadounidense de política
exterior vigente desde la segunda guerra
mundial
el horror vivido fue de tal dimensión
que provocó la rebelión de toda una
generación contra el imperio de la
fuerza y consiguió por ejemplo que las
guerras dejasen de ser populares en
hollywood desde entonces la memoria
colectiva se construyó a través de
películas denuncia cómo fueron platoon
la chaqueta metálica o 'apocalipsis now'
nadal punto cuelas y si lo has adivinado
hoy hablamos de vietnam un país que
marcó un antes y un después en la
historia de eeuu en este vídeo te
contamos que ha ocurrido desde entonces
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pues lo contamos en un vídeo anterior
vietnam es el país del mundo donde más
apoyo popular tiene el capitalismo en
concreto según datos del pew research
center el 93% de la población considera
que el libre mercado es el mejor modelo
posible un porcentaje muy superior al
que registra cualquier potencia
occidental
si amigos aunque resulte chocante hoy el
capitalismo y el libre mercado es más
popular en vietnam que en los mismísimos
eeuu es la demostración de que el
capitalismo es el mejor de los sistemas
del capitalismo más salvaje bien veamos
por qué
despegue de vietnam
en sólo unas pocas décadas vietnam ha
experimentado una transformación enorme
ha pasado de ser una sociedad agrícola a
convertirse en una pujante nación
industrial desde el año 2000 este país
ha vivido un auténtico boom económico y
su crecimiento anual medio ha sido de
casi el 7% al tiempo que la capacidad de
consumo de sus habitantes se ha
multiplicado por 6 en poco más de 15
años no está mal verdad es una gran
industria en lo que se refiere a la
inversión producción de equipos
transferencia de conocimientos educación
y por otra parte es desde luego una gran
oportunidad para el intercambio también
en materia deportiva cultural y en otros
sectores
kaiser cada vez son más las
multinacionales que anuncian inversiones
millonarias en este país
por ejemplo agarrados a la silla tan
sólo samsung ha anunciado inversiones en
este país por valor de 20 mil millones
de dólares casi nada
por qué
ese tipo
según pricewaterhousecoopers también
conocidos como el house water watch
cooper coaching se convertirá en una de
las principales ciudades del mundo en
apenas una o dos décadas y será una de
las dos ciudades que más crecerán de
aquí a 2025 así que si aún no tenéis
claro dónde está esta ciudad o queréis
hacer negocios ya la podéis buscar en el
mapa pero seguro que os preguntaréis no
es acaso vietnam un país comunista es
ésta una especie de triunfo del
comunismo pues no del todo
el comunismo en vietnam si es verdad
oficialmente el país continúa siendo una
dictadura comunista pero podemos decir
que es un modelo de apertura a la
inversión y al comercio exterior es muy
similar al que experimentó china tras
las reformas de deng xiaoping de las que
por cierto fonseca nos habló en este
vídeo así es que qué hizo den xiaoping
pues cambiará el sistema político a
trocitos y así es como surgió la idea de
las zonas económicas especiales pero
regresemos a vietnam aunque el país se
haya abierto al comercio y a la
inversión exterior es cierto que aún
muchas empresas siguen siendo propiedad
del gobierno concretamente casi la mitad
de las 500 mayores empresas del país
pero por otro lado también es verdad que
cada vez son más numerosos los planes
para privatizar muchas de estas empresas
y ojo el régimen vietnamita lo hace de
una forma muy capitalista en vez de
buscar a multinacionales para vender las
empresas públicas como es muy común por
ejemplo en latinoamérica en vietnam el
gobierno por lo que no
la saca a cotizar en su particular wall
street la bolsa de ho chi minh
[Música]
de esta forma cualquier persona puede
apostar por invertir en estas compañías
y desde luego el modelo es más
transparente consigue mejor la
recaudación del estado y no destruye la
competencia también hay otras
diferencias con china por ejemplo aunque
las exportaciones y las inversiones
industriales van viento en popa el
gobierno británica también ha dado
prioridad desde el principio a otras
áreas más ligadas a los servicios como
por ejemplo el turismo sin duda la mejor
muestra de todo esto es fukuoka island
una isla casi del tamaño de singapur que
el gobierno quiere convertir en una meca
internacional del turismo y el lógico
y para ello claro está ha confiado en el
mercado internacional
aquí los turistas no necesitan una visa
para entrar el gobierno ha construido
modernas infraestructuras y se han dado
muchas facilidades a que los inversores
internacionales lleguen con su dinero el
resultado es un impresionante boom de
hoteles resorts apartamentos parques
temáticos e incluso un casino los
proyectos en marcha se acercan a los 200
y las inversiones ya superan los 6 mil
millones de dólares desde luego ya os
podéis imaginar que las perspectivas son
ahora brillantes para los habitantes de
la isla que hasta ahora sobrevivían
gracias prácticamente a una pesca de
subsistencia y no sólo es eso la llegada
de turistas internacionales es un buen
conductor para nuevas ideas que
favorecen el aperturismo y el
entendimiento si amigos de visual
político durante los próximos años
vietnam darán mucho de qué hablar y en
washington lo saben
el pincel
obama y la apuesta por vietnam ya lo
sabéis es algo sobre lo que insistimos
bastante durante sus ocho años en la
casa blanca barack obama apostó fuerte
por el sudeste asiático y hay que decir
que vietnam fue uno de sus objetivos
procedentes de hecho el propio barack
obama visitó este país para dar un
carpetazo definitivo a las hostilidades
heredadas de la guerra no fue el primer
presidente en hacerlo tanto bill clinton
como george bush ya lo habían visitado
previamente pero obama ha sido
probablemente de los tres el que mejores
resultados logró obama logró la adhesión
de vietnam al famoso de pepe levantó el
embargo a la venta de equipos militares
a este país y nos dejó imágenes como
ésta
y en su búsqueda por lograr una estrecha
alianza con vietnam algo en lo que por
cierto tuvo éxito obama llegó a recibir
en la casa blanca al mismísimo
secretario general del partido comunista
chino así que sí para sorpresa de muchos
hay que decir que hoy vietnam el nuevo
tigre asiático es ya un aliado
estratégico de eeuu en fin qué pensáis
vosotros se convertirá quedan en una
nueva potencia asiática logrará donald
trump mantener la estrecha alianza
generada entre este país y estados
unidos esperamos que os haya gustado
este vídeo y aún no sabes que es este
botón es la nueva versión de ellos al
político en inglés así que si quieres
repasar la lengua de shakespeare no
dudes en hacer clic y suscribirte y si
tienes algún amigo angloparlante ya
sabes recomiéndanos un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]